tell me a joke Tom get serious ha ha ha
tell me a joke I can't I always forget
the punchline what is a great joke the
past present and future walking to a bar
it was tense do you have a boyfriend
it's just you and me Tom hey do you like
comedians this is about you Tom is there
a solution to the Palestinian question
in the Middle East no comment do you
believe in life after love I believe for
every drop of rain that falls a flower
grows ah I love you Siri oh I bet you
say that to all your Apple products hi
this is Tom Rhodes please join me as I
scour the four corners of the earth to
bring you interesting and intelligent
funny people who will enrich your life
with wisdom and laughter I'll take you
to Europe Australia all over America I
might take you to the peaks of Machu
Picchu the canals of Amsterdam the Great
Wall of China or the swamps of Florida
and certainly the many many comedy clubs
and comedy theaters all over the world
come hang out with me and meet the many
interesting people that pop up in my
life as I travel the world as a stand-up
comedian you're listening to some food
videos gotta kick baby rock and roll
welcome to Tom Rhodes radio thank you
for listening hey I want to start
today's episode by giving a shout out to
Eric in San Francisco I was at the
punchline in San Francisco last week as
you know that is my home club my holy
temple of the haha my Vatican of
stand-up comedy and eric is a big fan of
my podcast Tom Rhodes radio he came to
the punch line sat in the front row at
the very front table with his beautiful
wife and came up to me after the show
gave me twenty dollars and insisted that
I take it said that he's a fan loves the
podcast it enriches his world with
wisdom and laughter and I was really
touched man I think it's really cool
when people want to support me years ago
when I started out it was really
insulting when like some rich douchebag
would come up and want to like tip you
like I ain't your your valet punk or
your waiter but now it's different
because eric was like a genuine fan of
the podcast so that's different man if
somebody wants to buy me a meal or a
drink my tribe people that listen to my
podcast and he's a really cool guy I was
happy that I met him speaking of cool
human beings I got some really nice
questions on the ask me anything tell me
anything part on my Tom Rhodes radio.com
website uh so let me just go to the
mailbag as they used to call it when
people got mail the first one is from
Danny fingers Danny rides hey Tom what's
up man I am a longtime comic and a
musician now my band is called Danny
fingers and the thumbs based in New York
City you can hear us on Spotify anyway
my friend I love your podcast I listen
to all the episodes I love how he
matically you have made it an
international show talking about all the
different countries and all the other
wonderful cultures that are
this planet now I need some advice and I
figure who better ask advice than you on
this subject I'm going to Amsterdam on
Monday what would you recommend i do
karate kick baby well Danny number one
if you're in a band you should try and
get me a song or two that i might play
at the end of one of my episodes and
that could promote your music i'm going
to answer your question after you'll see
it goes along with Dave from Chicago
Dave wrote me he's going to Europe for
the very first time in June er September
and he's not sure where he should go
either Amsterdam or Malta now let me
just tell you this a lot of my favorite
places changed there was the Mets
department store where there was a cafe
on top and it was the best view of
Amsterdam now that place doesn't exist
anymore my favorite coffee shop was the
Roker I and that doesn't exist anymore
but you know there's some Amsterdam
perennials things I love to do number
one is vondelpark if you're there in
june or September it's the greatest
place in the world Danny if you're there
now in January it's you could probably
get into a snowball fight with some
school kids but vondelpark and summer is
one of the most exquisitely wonderful
places in the world riding a bike
through there rollerblading are just
walking around lying in the grass
vondelpark is my greatest Amsterdam tip
the Paradiso was a church built in like
the 14th century and now it's a
nightclub and they also do concerts
there the Rolling Stones played there I
personally saw india.arie there I saw
Jane's Addiction there the Paradiso and
when they don't have concerts it's like
disco dance night club dub techno music
but I've had the greatest nights of my
life in the Paradiso boom Chicago is now
in the Rosen gracht theater and that is
actually where I filmed my late night
talk show
and there is a comedy club in there
called bada boom in the small room and
in the big main room is where I filmed
my television show boom Chicago is great
tumor comedy club which is at the Hilton
the Amsterdam Hilton were John Lennon
and Yoko Ono did their love in to
protest the Vietnam War and yeah that
must have been really tough protesting
the Vietnam War from the Amsterdam
Hilton hey if my club him when she
doesn't show up from room service soon
this war is never gonna end anyway the
American hotel if you can afford it
that's where I like to stay man the
American hotel it's right on lines of
plane and it's just art deco hotel built
in like 1919 05 it's a beautiful hotel
very close to the Paradiso and
vondelpark that's the spot and those are
my best tips for Amsterdam oh oh oh
here's a small tip for Amsterdam soup
ins oh oh my god soup and zou when I
lived in Amsterdam I really became
addicted to soup and soup and zou
there's one by the Rembrandt house
there's two there's one on Spiegel
straat which is a pedestrian street
where all these antique stores are and
art galleries that's actually probably
my favorite Street in Amsterdam to ride
bikes on or walk down but that soup and
zou you can only tape take your soup to
go so if it's nice weather you can get
your soup and eat it on a canal
otherwise the soup and so that is beside
on the same block as the Rembrandt house
is the best place you can sit outside or
inside soup and zou every day has like
11 12 different kinds of soups and the
beautiful thing is you can sample them
you can mean oh um could I try the
potato Roquefort um can I try them
Moroccan chickpea and you can just you
know you give you little sips of it and
it's wonderful and they've raised their
prices through the years it used to be
like three euros for a large bowl of
soup now
like five euros but when it's cold and
amsterdam there's nothing better than
sticking your face over a hot bowl of
soup and a the Rembrandt house you can
go sit in the room that the great master
created in and that just titillates me
to no end and i love the Rembrandt house
I'm obsessed with the artist Rembrandt I
identify greatly with the artist
Rembrandt because I am also baroque
sorry couldn't resist a joke there but a
between the Rembrandt house and soup and
zou is the Communist bookstore and
there's no sign you'll see it and it's
been there since like the 70s I bought a
lot of subversive literature there and
also they sell pretty cool punk rock
angry anti-corporate t-shirts there
that's also great but Dave in Chicago
I've never been to Malta if you go to
Malta ashna and I have always wanted to
go to Malta and we are going to go for
no other fact then the Caravaggio
masterwork the beheading of John the
Baptist is in Malta Caravaggio became a
knight one of the Knights of Malta and
he painted this painting when he was on
the run accused her wanted for murder
and he had to get out of Italy and I've
said it so many times before Caravaggio
the beauty of his work is he makes
scenes from the Bible he depicts them as
the thuggish brutal street crime acts
that they were and the beheading of John
the Baptist the guy is holding down his
head John the Baptist his head and he's
got this knife the sheaf a shank that
he's pulling up behind his back and it's
just it's a brutal act as are most of
the incidents that happened in the Bible
so anyway go to both if you can Dave I'd
spent a couple days in Malta but it
always kills me when people only go to
Amsterdam for a few days at least spend
a week there and just walking around
stir damn Amsterdam itself is a work of
art and as much as the drugs and
prostitution gets all of the you know
the publicity it's the art that's
jumping out at you everywhere great
restaurants talk to people the Dutch are
so progressive and if you can read this
book aashna gave me this book last time
we were in Amsterdam and it's called
Amsterdam a history of the world's most
liberal city and it's written by Russell
shoretel fascinating book and it really
crystallized so many things of why I
love Amsterdam but there's the story in
there about how Amsterdam went from
becoming a small fishing village to a
city it's called the miracle of
Amsterdam it happened on culver straat
which is the pedestrian shopping street
and amsterdam this guy was dying they
gave him his catholic last rites he ate
his wafer and he vomited his communion
wafer and apparently it came out of his
mouth hole and it hovered over the fire
and it is called the miracle of
Amsterdam so all of these religious
pilgrims started coming from all over
Europe to come to M Street in because
this miracle had happened there and I
love the fact that Amsterdam grew from a
village into a city because a guy
vomited and so many people go there now
and vomit so there's something about
overindulgence and vomiting that is in
the core DNA of Amsterdam's creation my
other email that I got is from the Oscar
in the Netherlands he is one of the best
supporters of Tom Rhodes radio and has
become a very good personal friend of
mine he is going to the moontower comedy
festival in austin texas in april and he
wants some tips austin texas is probably
one of the coolest places in America I'd
say San Francisco Seattle Austin New
Orleans New York City those are my my
top places Chicago love you baby anyway
the moontower comedy festival is
wonderful and if you can afford it stay
at the stephen f austin intercontinental
hotel because that's where all the
comedians day so every they have big
acts all down to a new acts that you've
never heard of that will be famous in a
few years and so if you stay at the
intercontinental hotel that's where all
the comedians will be in the daytime
that's where they all congregate after
the festival shows the Paramount Theater
where the big headliners play is right
next door the other place I like to stay
is called the Austin motel and it's on
South Congress Avenue I it's a tiny old
hotel and only the three rooms that are
by this by the pool are really any good
and they're the most expensive rooms and
you have to get those booked like three
months in advance but the pool is great
there's a massive oak tree that hangs
over the pool and I think it's probably
one of the best pools in America or the
world to do running jump cannonball
splashes into and south congress avenue
directly across the street from the
austin motel is the continental club
which is one of the best rock and roll
rockabilly americana country music bars
in the world and in austin and also
about half a block up from there is
where all the food trucks are and like
western clothes cowboy shop so Austin is
great the food is great is great
barbecue great music if you want to get
boots or cowboy clothes but that
festival is really worth the trip I
think it's one of the best comedy
festivals
it's definitely the best comedy festival
in the United States so it's a great
trip to go there and I hope you get to
meet lots of cool comedians should I
tell the story on the upper balcony of
the Intercontinental there's the bar so
all the comedian's congregate there I
did the first two moon tower festivals
there were so many comedians out there
and Steven Wright was coming and walking
in our direction and there was a hot
asian girl standing beside me and he was
obviously coming to talk to her so I
have to tell you Steven Wright is
wearing a Boston Red Sox baseball hat
and in the 1950s the Boston Red Sox had
a player named jimmy piersall and jimmy
piersall i had a few nervous breakdowns
on the field during games his father
nothing he did was good enough for his
father his father pushed him
relentlessly he'd hit two home runs in a
game and his father would say well you
still had an error at third base and so
it drove jimmy piersall crazy and
there's a famous incident in the 50s
where he climbed up on the backstop
behind home plate at Fenway Park after
he hit home run hit a home run and he
climbed up on the backdrop and he was
yelling at his father is that good
enough for you dad is that good enough
for you dad and they actually made a
movie starring Anthony Perkins called
fear strikes out and it's about Jimmy
Pierce's life okay so Steven Wright is
walking towards me people are stopping
him saying things to him I know I've got
like two words two sentences to say to
this guy and so he's walking up to me I
stick my hand out i said hi Steven my
name is Tom Rhodes I'm a stand-up
comedian and he goes hey nice to meet
you and I go I just want you to know
that I think jimmy piersall was the most
underrated comedy talent ever to come
out of boston and steven rights kind of
a kind of an older man now and he cocked
his head and he he looks up from under
his baseball hat at me and he goes
really why and I said when he climbed up
on that back
stop and yelled at his father is that
good enough for you dad I said that was
comedy brilliance and Steven Wright went
hahahaha he let out this great bellowing
laughs and I'm glad that I met Steven
Wright and I only got to talk to him for
less than two minutes and i made the man
laughs and then he moved on to the hot
asian girl that was talking to him
anyway that's my my tip and hopefully
you'll get to meet Steven Wright or
whoever your comedy hero is at the
Austin moontower comedy festival I want
to thank Danny Dave and Yas / for taking
the time to reach out to me and write me
and ask me questions on Tom Rhodes
radio.com and i want to remind everybody
when you have a chance take a look at
Tom Rhodes net which I have just
revamped that website and I am
dedicating my video content to Tom
Rhodes dotnet and my podcast and audio
content will be on Tom Rhodes radio com
anyway they were created strictly for
your amusement enjoy
beat
Jane its life
you
today's guest is Steve Wozniak yes wow
that Steve Wozniak and I'm just as
impressed as you are that he's my guest
on this podcast I met Steve Wozniak last
month a few weeks before Christmas i was
performing at the improv in Lake Tahoe
and he came to my show turns out the guy
loves humor loves jokes loves comedians
he had been to the improvident in Lake
Tahoe many times he knows how we nave
the comedian who runs the place and is
the house MC there they're old friends
and I talked to Steve after the show
wonderfully approachable beautiful human
being and very easy to talk to he gave
me his card I sent him a few emails and
the man graciously agreed to get
together and make time for me to make
this recording so last week i was in san
francisco and i drove down to cupertino
california and i met steve at the
mandarin oriental restaurant on de anza
boulevard and i mentioned that only
because during this recording you're
going to hear some very pleasant lovely
violin based classical music that is
playing in the background I asked the
lovely chinese man who owned the place
if he would mind turning off the music
while we recorded this and he said no
that that was not possible so anyway
thank God it wasn't some annoying pop
music that's playing in the background
so there is this like pleasant violin
classical music in the background and
the other degree of difficulty for this
conversation we only had like an hour he
said to meet him at five o'clock and
Steve Wozniak was walking into that
restaurant at 459 p.m. the man was
punctual right on time what I did not
expect was Steve or the woz as he likes
to be called um he brought his wife
her parents and another elderly couple
so I wasn't expecting an audience so we
sat at this big round table in this
Chinese restaurant and all of these
people were sitting there listening and
watching and I'm proud of myself that I
stayed focused during this interview and
at the end of this conversation a very
large party of about 10 or 12 people
noisily came to the table next to us so
there was a lot of distractions and
noises and things I wasn't expecting but
I'm proud of the way this came off and
you'll see steve wozniak is such an
intelligent guy was so much going on in
his brain you ask him one questions and
it's such a complex speedy answer but
that's the exciting thing about talking
to steve wozniak is is what comes out of
his brain when you ask him things in the
research that ashna and i did for this
podcast it seemed like everybody asked
him countless questions about apple and
steve jobs so i purposefully stayed away
from any questions having to do with
anything Apple and I basically wanted to
focus on his love of humor and jokes I
really wanted to delve into Internet
freedom cyber attacks things like that
that are so pertinent in world events
right now so those questions we we
didn't get as deep on those as I wanted
and then at the end of this conversation
for some reason I'm talking about my mom
a lot and her use of technology but
maybe that was because these older
people were at the table but anyway the
man is the co-founder of the Apple
Corporation with the now deceased Steve
Jobs and in my opinion no human being
since Gutenberg and his invention of the
printing press has improved human life
and the quality of human living
more than today's guests and that is why
it is my pleasure to present to you now
the one and only Steve Wozniak
steve wozniak ladies and gentlemen Steve
Wozniak uh thank you for transforming
the world and making my life easier as
human being but thanks very much now I
did want to transform the world but I
didn't want to be known for it I was I
want to be the site white guy stay in
the laboratory keep designing new
products and what other people go out
there get known for it what do you think
about all this notoriety does it make
you feel uncomfortable that you know
you're kind of worshipped the world over
it only it's been comfortable in the
sense that you know what people want a
few little symbols people to attribute
you to a lot of the things they have in
their life that are good and where did
it come from like it came from one
person it came from hundreds of
thousands of people I did one part I did
it very well I was kindly I genius all
that and was ahead of the world but um
but the trouble you know so it's the
whole idea you didn't do that much
differently there are other people just
as smart just as good doing the quantum
physics to make chips work a certain way
that you know made a lot of it possible
and you never hear about them but I'm
just glad the World got to where it got
to I'm glad the computers had the effect
on society because when i started i
heard social psychologists social
scientists from Stanford and Berkeley
talking about all the great social
change that having your own computer
could bring and that was in the day when
you just thought you'd have to sit down
the computer type in some programs learn
a programming language and get out some
answers and it was only text types
thinking it was early like thinking but
they talked about communication
improving education improving and just
being a geek too knew how to use a
computer and being more able being more
of a master of things in the world and
that's what drove me i had my talent was
I could design anything in the world
almost so simple solo parts and I I knew
though I instantly saw the formula to
make an affordable useful computer other
people saw ways to make affordable non
usual computers and so I jumped in for
that reason and now to see the social
benefits have gone so far beyond what we
ever imagined but it was really what was
through the driving influence on all of
us in the homebrew Computer Club I
always liked the sentence that the sum
total of all human knowledge can be
found on the Internet unfortunately that
that is true and it makes a sound like
we are so superior to any other like
species on earth right or anyone from
previous generations and sometimes I go
in my own thinking I think maybe it's
just because we stumbled on the steps
that took us into a tool that took this
to the neck the tips of the next and if
we for example if we gave up everything
electronic can just right now today we
gave it up maybe even cars just
everything mechanical everything uses
energy if we suddenly gave it up we have
to go way way way back to the pre fossil
fuel days and we wouldn't look that
superior in every way if we had to give
up you know certain things that we
develop and even language maybe other
species have their own language that's
as interpreted and developed as ours and
have parts parts of grammar and you know
adverbs of entrance maybe they do in
their ways and we'd never know it we
don't we know so little about you know
we think oh my gosh we're going to find
and study species from other other
planetary systems other stars you know
the sole adjustment and somehow we'll be
able to communicate with them we can't
even communicate with our own and uh
normal animals and I know actually I'm
kind of tell that some of them seem to
be smarter in our ways like dolphins you
know but but aside from that we don't
really know how smart they are what
their brains do as a computer person to
sink of making a computer with the
artificial intelligence to do what an
ant does it's hard to you know it's hard
to imagine and then we have other
animals that don't look so smart like
cows and my joke is that the you can
make the smartest cow in the world if
you transplant at the brain of an amped
into it they've got a little social
colonies into building all these mounds
that you look at our roads we have a
complicated system if you look at a map
roads and roads and roads are they ever
end just like all the ant holes never
end but the ant holes are working in
three dimensions see and we're only
working in two dimensions for the most
part we rarely go to that third
dimension so so they might be smarter
than us and those I always thought that
because we spent so much time with our
without looking at computer screens that
it through evolution our eyes are going
to get bigger our hunting skills are
going to be less our noses will get
smaller our ears will look like aliens
and I think aliens are us from the
future come back to visit ourselves yeah
I look at that more in the metal sense
you're looking at a physical sense shape
I think in the metal sense we are maybe
less what we're going with us a brain or
something we're more what tools we have
defined what we will do and be and the
tools pass on to the you know
continually throughout the years you
know so so we might not have every time
we create sup we can't give up that
thing has become more of a master to us
and I feel that people often talk about
a battle of the robots versus to humans
and that could come to be like the movie
her if they ever get conscious but I the
way I first say it see it as we lost
that battle 200 years ago Industrial
Revolution we can never go back and give
up our lifestyle we'd never ever undo a
piece of it and say hey it's better
humans do these things on their own what
do you think that an Elon Musk in
Stephen Hawking lately have been given a
gloomy prognosis about artificial
intelligence that were ultimately
building what will destroy ourselves in
the few i hope the other listeners know
what they've been saying but I'm gonna
tell you something I have been on stage
around the world as a public speaker
saying the exact same things for two
years talking about the fear talking
about what I've seen how I've seen
artificial intelligence develop thinking
it would be nothing and all of a sudden
realizing it's going to happen computers
are currently at conscious in 20 years
by the formulas you know records while
and then I always wound up with the
absolute scariest most negative what do
you think of esperance because here's
what happens what happens is okay a
machine you take a machine out there and
it can you know lay a bunch of asphalt
or dig holes in the ground it can do so
much more than a human being if we talk
about a machine that has 10,000
horsepower in every horse is so many
humans humans don't do the manufacturer
the work you know the real work of
products anymore if you talk about that
and then you look you think that's
replacing like human muscles we have
replaced them and we won't go back or
we'd have to give up a lot but what
about the brain now will computers ever
equal the brain all my life I said no
artificial intelligence is a phony scam
machine that can pick up a blue dot a
blue ball and put it in a blue box is
not thinking you know even though simple
rules of
of tic-tac-toe or checkers is not much
thinking now that playing chess with us
so their simulated intelligence not real
intelligence but in recent times we're
getting closer to real artificial
intelligence machines that really
understand what we're saying and
slightly speak into our phones and I'll
grant you it's very we have very simple
techniques to make serious seem
intelligent knowing what words in a
dictionary mean but Google's not even
further Google knows what words mean
according to what people are searching
for so you have a word in a dictionary
like the word um tablet okay i'm looking
at tablet right here well what if
there's a politician somewhere in the
world named tablet that is having a big
scandal this week and it's in all the
press and everybody searching for who
who will know when you use a word with
tablet that you might mean the guy and a
dictionary definition might not so we're
getting closer and closer and i look at
google also for the searching because we
never invented a thing in technology for
the on the internet saying the internet
is going to be the brain of the future
that isn't how we thought we just want
to extend communication channels and
share files and make up things operator
from our long distance away and then we
eventually we need everybody could
publish in the dial-up days they could
publish things on the internet and we
needed to search for it there was so
much so we got a search engine and now
used to ask a smart person with a big
brain a difficult question now who do
you ask it starts with geo and it's not
gone that's what I say that's my job i
remember when i lived in san francisco
in the early 90s you could call the
Oakland Public Library and ask them
anything and that was the first thing I
thought when like will be a mill was
like oh my god a yes and that was that
was a good service that was like it was
amazing to you there was a number you
could call it what if that continues
what if what if computers are you
holding your hand they're starting to
get so personal people hold them close
to their body their brain waves social
psychologists have said or social
neuropsychologist have said um simulate
are very similar to ones that are people
are in love with something that's sort
of their route to the world not the
people that are walking by them on the
side welfare even see those people
anymore they're just sort of into their
machine whatever's on it is their world
and you thought is it like a person
could it ever be a person but if it got
a conscious what if had feelings what
I've looked at my face and even knew
what i was thinking from facial
expressions this is scary are we going
to get there and unfortunately we're on
the path and what if the machine could
think better than as well as me what if
it's think better than me someday twice
fast ten times as fast 100 times as fast
as any human that means that any
computer will pop up the instant
financial strategies for a company
better than the CEOs is run a company or
look at look at the big investment
trading houses eighty percent of the
financial trades of the world are going
through computers in thousands of a
second and they're skipping the slow
humans because they win by skipping the
slow humans wonderful company opens up
across the street from Apple does all
the same things apples doing but it has
no slow humans just computers directing
all the computers and robots on this
night um that's a scary thought where do
we wind up as you lose out economically
you lose out you know and if these
things can really think better and
faster than us some yeah I i I'm
frightened of that and like like Stephen
Hawking I think that this sort of
thinking is driving Hawking and Elon
Musk and founders of Google have said
some more things um and I'm hoping it
doesn't get there so the way I found a
way out of the pessimism is Moore's law
starts saying I believe Moore's Law is
approaching its limit and that's based
on I've done work for fusion-io using
NAND flash memory chips the ultimate
chip product in the world the ultimate
memory product of the world the densest
highest density you know the only amount
of memory that could really start
approaching a brain and we're storing
the difference between a zero and a one
in eight electrons eight electrons you
can make the chips a little smaller pack
more bits in by going to a sizable needs
only stored in six electrons but now you
have to add more bits of error
correction and you lose you can't make
the chip more dense you can't get more
memory on with the chip more smart on a
chip than last year and i do believe
we're near the end of it somebody
recently i'm trying to think it was only
famous said they're related to chips but
they said that they believe we're near
the end of moore's law it was another
person making the same point because
we're down to like five you know eight
to five eight in layers on the chip and
you can't go more if
go lesson that you start getting a whole
bunch of anomalies and circuit problems
so we won't be able to make the chips
that smart maybe and I'm hoping that
Moore's lost all things enough that
humans still retain control Wow forever
hopefully so these are a long time so
and we're Ray Kurzweil says that the
computers will equal our ability to
process data in 20 years I say 20 to 200
to cover things like that because 200
years discover here you know what
forever what do you envision is the
worst case scenario just like drones
having to destroy our little house keys
keeper robots well my head kept drawing
it out this was self-driving cars 01 in
doses for about two years about two
years before the movie herb and I always
get what the conclusion that well the
robots would think we're gods at first
because we created them and that might
hold forever but it probably won't but
at least we created them to take care of
our needs and so will be taken care of
like family pets but you know what in
the end those computers aren't going to
need those machines aren't going to need
fresh air like we do they aren't going
to have the same needs and secondly our
slow communication isn't going to be
enough and then I saw the movie her much
later than most people when I saw it I
said oh my god that's exactly what I
think it was I figured would be the
alleys dating is over if they can hold
you know 10,000 communications at the
same time with their own people so
they're born with a human even if
they're in love and so that's that's a
scary thought that I hope does not
happen you know because we can't give up
any of the stuff you can't say oh we
will turn off the internet will turn off
every single because then we couldn't do
any of the things we do in our life to
even get an income right yeah where it
was animal oh my god such a huge change
in lifestyle then maybe that would be a
death maybe that's a new factor for
extinction but but and then you know and
ever since we made these machines that
we can't give up I decided that's the
factor that made the machines the
winners with the Industrial Revolution
we will do whatever we can make with
machines and not just disappear humans
mr. Theodore Twombly welcome to the
world's first artificially intelligent
operating system we'd like to ask you a
few questions okay are you social or
antisocial is Evan social well how would
you describe your relationship with your
mother thank you please wait as your
operating system is initiated hello I'm
here hi hi I'm Samantha good morning
Theodore morning you have a meeting in
five minutes you want to try getting
head back to fun okay good and funny how
am i learning everything about
everything I love for you look for
how long before you're ready to date oh
do you mean I sign your emails that you
come to a breakup well you're kind of
nosy so was it like being married
there's something that feels so good
about sharing your life with somebody
how do you share your life with somebody
yeah guess it just been having fun you
really deserve that
in a long time since I've been with
somebody that I felt totally at ease for
jadi stay optimistic well I found my way
I'm always optimistic because first of
all you I have a lot of smiles I tell a
lot of jokes I play a lot of friends I
do a lot of fun things in my life and a
lot of entertainment I go to I go to
music go to comment I met you at a
comedy show and I saw mark and um that
so that's one thing and then I avoid the
frowns and I void the frowns by you
can't avoid a hundred percent because
i'll tell you i've been around computers
I've developed a puter sophomore when I
see it working horribly and miss
communicated to me and misleading me I
hate those devices when something just
totally fails why did it shut down why
did it crash there is no reason for this
is horrible horrible why do they ship
this stuff I you get upset at those sort
of things but basically almost
everything in life i say i don't i'm not
going to care so much i'm going to have
a worry think about the day trader in
stocks or everybody's running around and
then the gram of financial papers first
thing in the morning Sam this is this is
a point about 38 cents oh my god this
one's down you know two percent you know
and they're worried they're calling her
stockbrokers you're worrying and
worrying worrying when I was young I
heard about medication get yourself into
a calm state and I always try to remain
in a calm state and in a calm state you
don't want the stress you don't want
stress you don't want drama you don't
want to hear all these things yeah so I
really think you know pretty much most
of things in life I figured out already
whichever way they go I'm okay I've
learned that over a long lifetime I've
learned about time I was 20 it doesn't
matter who gets elected to office really
i don't have to have those worries if i
buy a new car and it gets scratched or
dead end cars get scratched and dented
and i can live with it and deal with it
and i don't have to oh my daughter mo
upset about it so i don't really get
upset about very many things at all and
it's only computer technical things
because i feel partly responsible you
know i would i would have never wanted
to make devices that were like that to
humans but you know you gotta have to
Rashid yourself from bad news of the
world last month I was in I took my
mother to Key West and we're about to
get on a boat to go on a sunrise cruise
and I looked at my phone my iphone and
breaking news that Australia
terrorists in the cafe the hidden is
killed that we like sitting that it is
before we were in Sydney that day yeah I
was speaking and they had to have me do
the second part of my speech two days
later because the the rest of their
company couldn't get across town to get
there ya know that time to shut down
yeah one of my favorite cities like a
widow but on the other side of the world
in two minutes later if they see so
father me like I'm thinking oh my god
it's terrible you know what we're always
gonna have terrorism we're always do
that murders wrong can have criminals
there's no way you're gonna stop that
yeah so I just think if I don't have the
power to stop something I long ago in my
life I said I don't have the power to
change it then I'm not going to worry
about it why should I even address it
it's just like I'm an observer we're
almost all observers and we have
feelings oh my gosh you know somebody
somebody's getting hurt somebody's doing
something bad wrong you know you can
look out on the street here in San Jose
didn't see that every day right
I am leaving soon and you will forgive
me if I speak bluntly the universe grows
smaller every day and the threats of
aggression by any group anywhere can no
longer be tolerated there must be
security for all or no one is secure now
this does not mean giving up any freedom
except the freedom to act irresponsibly
your ancestors knew this when they made
laws to govern themselves and hired
policemen to enforce them we have the
other planets have long accepted this
principle we have an organization for
the mutual protection of all planets and
for the complete elimination of
aggression the test of any such higher
authority is of course the police force
that supports it for our policemen we
created a race of robots their function
is to patrol the planets in space ships
like this one and preserve the peace in
matters of aggression we have given them
absolute power overs this power cannot
be revoked at the first sign of violence
they act automatically against the
aggressor the penalty for provoking
their action is too terrible to risk the
result is we live in peace without arms
or armies secure in the knowledge that
we are free from aggression and war free
to pursue more profitable enterprises
are we do not pretend to have achieved
perfection but we do have a system and
it works I came here to give you these
facts it is no concern of ours how you
run your own planet but if you threaten
to extend your violence this earth of
yours will be reduced to a burned-out
cinder
your choice is simple join us and live
in peace or pursue your present course
and face obliteration we shall be
waiting for your answer the decision
rests with you now in an interview with
metafilter you said you always wanted to
be a stand-up comedian did you ever do
any open mic nights did I really say
that no I know I know I know I always
admired them i would i would have liked
to be a stand-up comedian i liked i was
trying to make up little jokes and
things in daily life as an amateur next
to me a stand-up comedian is a
professional I think long term here
matures the world of gloom an amateur
but basically it's being able to be
creative enough to think of things on
the fly that will sound a little funny
like yesterday I met seth rogen just
said it's gonna be funny when he gets
balled they didn't get it so I had to
tell himself throw game but um you know
but I just I thought I things up on the
cruise I oh my gosh we had take your
little rides on the tenders to get into
the ports and all that so I saw my job
he came to of what's the gentlest way to
get off the boat in a tender you know
but I'm doing this all the time every
day I come up with a few of these I
probably came up with one on the way
here and I forget what it was you know
they don't memorize them so I love you
more because it keeps me smiling and
happy I love it more than anything when
when I married to somebody who laughs at
my jokes and and I've been lucky that
way that's everything my wife to my god
what is the best laugh you've had lately
I couldn't remember i I'm so happy and
smiling all he just comes yeah you know
it was it was there was something i was
laughing out loud today on the internet
or some joke a friend sent me and i
forget what it was I'd have to go back
to my computer and NC is yeah now you
sometimes sometimes i do remember them
really good they're really really
hilarious oh I know the one I saw
yesterday but I watch it about once a
month it's an old onion episode on this
this guy he's like he's like a
legislator and they show him in the
legislation room with the madam madam
madam second to thank you literally
neither but ain't proposes this new bill
but they changed the work through the
school [__] now to prevent school
[__] you know it talks about how
horrible it every day you read about
somebody you know who went blind because
I got to two gang members slow [__] them
at the farthest at the same time
simultaneously or you know it's full of
jokes like that and I laugh all the way
through that one it is so funny but the
kid who can't remember fractions of the
he was an honor student can't more
fractions anymore because human
ejaculate in is burning it's like you're
looking at the guy you say this is like
looks like it's really happening I've
sent it to a few people that weren't
totally in on the known they thought it
was read you were the owner of the first
dial a joke service in the San Francisco
Bay Area and was run out of a kitchen in
cupertino yes and I'm pretty sure that
at that time there was only only other
Joe Klein you could call a phone number
and get a joke was zzzzz in Los Angeles
um don't know how that one happened to
exist but I had been a phone freak so I
could call anywhere in the world and i
discovered in other countries they had
dialer jokes why didn't they have one
here when i decided i'm going to set one
up i'm going to be the first in the
whole San Francisco Bay Area there's a
you were not allowed to catch your own
equipment to the phone lines back then
18t had a strong monopoly nobody was
allowed to catch their own equipment
there could be no other manufacturers or
phones you could get your one black
phone from AT&T or your one coda phone
seven hundred answering machine all the
theaters used it that's money that you
lose business so they paid a lot of
money I was a young you know engineer
just out of college and a didn't finish
college really but you know your
apartment rental is your most biggest
expense this was half as much again as
the apartment rental just to rent an
answering machine that's why i was first
it costs a lot of money and what I did
was I made all the jokes are really
short I used the jokes of the day that
were popular then they're not allowed
now polish jokes and when the Polish
people were upset you know I said what
if I change them to Italian jokes and
they said okay this is I'm just I'm
saying that to illustrate it was before
political correctness and now they get
upset if you tell a joke that's not even
really an ethnic joke but it just uses
an ethnic were like what do you call
four Mexicans in quicksand quatro sinko
its not Sam Mexicans are bad they're
greasy or lazy or dom or anything that's
a joke but i would
jokes and I would make them really short
on my answering machine I loved them
before dialing dial it joke though there
is a joke ease and I'd make a short joke
so I can get through about two thousand
calls a day and I assume i probably had
the most called see the line number a
number without an extension like the
whole big company would get more calls
but I might have been the large spelled
number in the United States but you were
actually doing the jokes it was your
every morning I ordered a new voice
because but I could only rent the one
machine the phone company had I had sort
of a machine so i guess it came from
some inventor some I had an illegal one
that I could use if I wanted but I used
the phone cutting machine and it broke
down once a month from the high volume
of calls once a month but guess what I
got to call them up and say claimant
bring a new machine every month I want a
new machine after every month they had
to replace this hugely expensive thing I
felt I was doing my little thing to Nick
the phone company you know because a
they forced me to buy theirs they won't
let me use mine one time at one time
very funny thing they I put a note on i
called him up said make sure they come
after five when i get home from work I
worked at Google Packard and I came home
with five there's a note on my door they
were there earlier so I called up again
make sure they come after five cuz I
gotta be here and the next day I came as
a note on my door we came into and you
weren't there ok next I call them you
know really upset and they they the next
day they also they blow it again so now
i got i called him up real peaceful and
i said please have the guy come out
tomorrow after five and i put on my
illegal answer machine with a message
saying yeah well then we can put a
battling dial a joke water machine is
broken in the phone company hasn't faced
it if you want valid joke back dial 61
fun and have girlfriends style too i
came home from work at five p.m. that
night and I disconnected the it illegal
answering machine you know and then I
went out with my own phone and I called
611 and I said I have a complaint they
said I now dial a joke I said how did
you know and they said every other call
today has been for pile of junk
haha as proud of that what is your
favorite jerk I don't have a favorite
just too many I mean back when the
police show up days I could probably
name one who's a favorite but can't say
it now great and now there's so many
jokes I I could probably pick out a few
it's songs you know you can go start
making a list of all the songs you
remember that are your favorites right
as you get older and older you might
wind up with 100 songs in your top
category so if I went up 100 jokes in my
top category I would remember him that
well um for Mexicans a quick said it's
not a bad that's a great joke yeah you
know if you ask Siri on the iphone for a
joke it used to say I can never remember
the punchlines and then just do that to
me yesterday was the last like year or
something it said the past the future
and the president walked into a bar it
was tense and then we just tried it
again today because we were thinking
about this and it said you wouldn't
understand the jokes of my language
shouldn't this yesterday yesterday I see
like the dial a job where like every
time you ask it it's a difficult joke
yeah we have fun with Siri sometimes so
much at night wolf this F some will say
hey Siri you know because it's our folks
are plugged in and trouble is five
phones Lancer um what about your you're
notorious prankster what is what are the
greatest pranks you've ever pulled I
pull them to this day someone to put
money and time into them I was just on a
cruise ship and they have ipads with
that we're only could get you to a news
feed of news articles may this one
little floating button and he pushed it
enough you get kind of you could
eventually get to where you could get to
the settings so i turned the screen
inverted colors on a few and then what I
did was I went I did the yo Gil standard
thing I took a snapshot of the settings
page a screen snapshot and I made it the
background I move all the cursors over
to a secondary homepage off to the right
even the cursors at the bottom even the
apps at the bottom so now whenever you
even went home it just brought up a
picture of the settings and nothing
worked as it was a picture so I you know
I did that but then what i would i'd
like to do is I'd like to UM
and I also set a bunch of alarms to go
off with a cricket sound at like 2am 3m
at 4am at night and then the last night
to sit set it to go off every 17 hours
and 13 minutes I picked some weird
number but crickets and then we were
talking to the captain on the ship
turned out they had had a cricket
infestation two weeks before I mean
Indonesian and said they're still here
ice Italy so there's still here and I
said oh they're down below he said no no
they're up here and they were on our
floor where we'd done it and Janet would
walk into that like the main center of
the room of the ship and she's here
cricket sounds going off on somebody
hold in a night but they actually
thought they said you don't change them
anymore because the chosen and they just
hiding you never catch them and we just
dumped water in and there's nothing we
need to do so they've given up on even
looking for it that was a good one but
yeah back in past years I always
remember to pranks 11 i like very much
that I'd forgotten about 450 years have
now remember in high school I am I put a
notice read to all the students on the
TV system in the hall rooms and it said
a certain time in room Stanford's head
janitor would speak on higher custodial
education okay so guess what up the kids
in the class would laugh like you and
the teachers would say no no that's real
that the janitors you know that's an
honorable profession they make a lot of
good money that's what they did that's
what heavily diff thought it was real
the proper amount of lemon pledge the
mix with dr oxford and there were two
that i tried to do with steve jobs that
were great back in the years before once
we had apple he would only be straight
businessman and only business made it
you know not go back to thinking of
ideas for creative pranks and all that
but that before that we did one where we
went to on the the seniors come off a
graduation and one and a half of them
come off by this one building the c
building and we had this idea to have a
sheet that will pull down from the seen
them turns out that you can't put a
sheet on top of building and yang
something to pull the sheet down it the
physics don't work out so we had was a
sheet that would flap around they have
to put shoes on top of it so we finally
came up with an arrangement let's make a
little axelrad
took four nights four nights going up at
midnight work until four in the morning
to get this thing done it was my usual
mostly my friend Alan Bam and I state
Steve Jobs dropped out after a couple
nights made the thing that would roll
down a ramp like with a little axle
between it and we just kind of cut a
fishing line it would start rolling down
it would pull and then from both sides
it would pull the sheet off the side
that she had a little flip off finger
saying best wishes and we actually
signed it we actually signed it swab job
the SW in swamp was for me the ad was in
swab was for Alan bound and the job is
for jobs and and we if four nights we
finally wound up with one scape on one
ramp one skate on another ramp and by
the way everything is tied with ropes
even the shoes that were holding down
the sheets are wouldn't blow away
everything is tied with ropes so nothing
would fall off the building on some
what's it we did a good job and trouble
is the last night where after Steve Jobs
told some other seniors pull on a
different senior prank you know fill in
the quadrant waters I'm told them where
our wire was and everything to cut and
they cut it because one of them told me
that's how it happened the next year
Ballmer so it didn't come off it was a
really good idea the next one though is
even better Steve Jobs had found out
where the shed where you turned on all
the sprinklers at the school were and
during graduation the parents would sit
on the football field so the idea was we
were going to pull a fishing line turn
on the sprinklers on the fishing feet
the the football field and I came up
with the idea we'll also epoxy the panel
shut so the jander can't run over and
turn it off because we did a test at
Cupertino high school of football game
we did during a football game and
somebody ran over and opened the thing
up and turned it off turn the sprinkler
off so we were going to epoxy it shut so
they couldn't do that and troubles would
went out to the shed at midnight with a
mark pick guy that I knew it perfectly
and he couldn't pick his way in I climb
on top and I got a thing thing off the
top and I could get him to half the shed
but the wrong half not where the
controls would so that one didn't come
off but it was a good idea what was he
last month you told me there was some
trick you can do with the with the
iphone or that you can program it to
like alarms go off that the story you
were just telling me that if somebody's
a cup somebody is similes our phone
around table they leave it there look on
the other way talking to somebody else
you take your phone presser you don't
know any of their lock codes or anything
and set an alarm for 3am and man oh yeah
we've done that a number of times we've
done it a lot to the comedian that South
Lake Tahoe how he made a lot of time to
juvie him not only that he told me once
he was going to have this this this
comedian on his show from LA I forget
her name right now but I could remember
Wendy Wendy Leah Leah right she's gonna
be on his show and he was gonna do it to
her phone cuz I thought about it you oh
man I she's a friend too but I'm sorry I
just been on a radio show with her so I
told her what he was going to do to her
and I told her you've got to do it to
him she did and he was so upset when his
when his phone went off that morning his
wife made him get out of bed and turn it
off yeah she got in and he does it keeps
coming to him and he knows it's coming
from me somehow you know I have I'm
prone to over exaggeration but I don't
think it's any over exaggeration that
not since Gutenberg's printing press as
anyone improves human life more than you
but what about internet personal freedom
and the limitations of free speech on
the internet like other the Paris
attacks over the that was obviously not
anything of the intent the intent was to
make humans more the masters of their
world able to do things with cleverness
and use their brains and get more done
than they ever could before and also
when communication came we were going to
have oh my gosh we've got all this
communication we've got you know and
trouble is it's electronic and it has
codes and people can listen to a radio
if you think of cell phones in the old
analog cell phone days you could buy a
radio to an end listen to calls but once
it's digital its bits and nobody can
figure it out the only trouble is
because it was digital it could also
have codes put in on each end and those
codes could be controlled by others and
and censorship was possible and
listening in observation I I'm very
upset about that i'm one of the founders
of the eff so and i'm one of the three
people actually put in the money i was
on the first board and everything is any
beach foundation it's the ACLU of of
technical of computer stuff they have
fought copyright cases even against
Disney and your friend they've the
lawsuit against the NSA
whether it got dropped or not I don't
know but they were there they jump on
these civil liberties cases I believe
very strongly people have civil
liberties right to their own privacy and
you know if anything is I share myself
I'm totally open I just share so much of
it Gong schedules I would never have a
list of phone number in my life because
of my personal philosophies that anybody
who wants when I will stand up for if
they think if somebody thinks they have
a secure phone call then they should
have a secure phone call it's wrong for
them to think that and oh no I was sure
that comes in my mind that consumer the
lowdown user products is much more
important than the producer that the the
people with power and wealth should be
equal to the people who actually don't
and and those who are the users really
deserve deserve respect and credit and
we don't operate that way anymore we're
not a good way I was brought up with
those you know being told that by my
father that that's what our country
country was about and it's so wrong now
well uh yeah I know you you're all about
you know empowering people and my life
has been transformed from apple products
my podcast is as a comedian everything I
do I don't need the approval of
Hollywood you know executives or
anything and and you have the power to
reach the world and creativity what
you're doing this are formed creativity
and we have things like garageband that
musicians can use computers to create
things they have to order this on yeah
and we have and we have from we have so
many so many ways to be creative editing
videos right on your own computer in
your own house so people with almost
right now you can make their own their
own movies and I know that's that's
incredible side of it that we've
unleashed creativity in the machines as
steve jobs at the bicycle of the mind
that the only thing that made it man
above what is it storks or something
like that for ability to run a certain
distance with how much energy was the
bicycle but man and the number one
position among all the animals so the
bicycle the line means you can use the
Creator the computer to be can be
creative to get more than you could have
done by yourself yeah that's the good
side yeah you know
I've only an Apple was the first
computer I ever bought that's all I've
ever bought I bought my 75 year old
mother a computer and she was terrified
of computers I told my mom i said just
just start clicking around and she loves
it she's figured it out so i skipped
that but you might have done it in a
more recent you computer czar reliable
now and easy to use especially tablets
back when you had modems you had motive
settings things were always wrong you
were getting told this and you couldn't
understand the error messages I would
not give my mother a computer because
she would have gotten frustrated at her
age 70 s and she would have quit the
internet never seen it forever but I
waited till web TV came webtv you push
one button and on your TV set the
internet comes up you don't have to know
or do anything start browsing through a
few categories you can do very little
but it did or nothing she was on the
internet every day for ages I I'm you
know I bought my mom a macbook so we
could skype when I'm on the road and
stuff and she loves to cook so she looks
up YouTube videos of recipes and and
things like that so easy but it's even
easier for her now because she can speak
her smart phone maybe and say say face
fine yeah yeah that's the she's still
terrified to make that leap that's the
next thing that I'm gonna try and get
her into the once you take that voice
sleep man you discover there's a lot of
using things now that you didn't have to
memorize any procedures and I started by
myself really hate a lot of the
procedures and processes and structure
and organization that's on my smart
product my phones and light and my
tablets if I can just speak it I don't
have to think of anything I just say
what's on my mind and it often works not
always but often the it seems like a lot
of hacking a lot of hackers do things
just because it's hilarious the North
Korea hacking into Sony I mean that was
a bucket of cold water into western
societies faced it's all yeah I could
have I don't necessarily buy that yet
you know and you think they did or know
somebody always takes credit for any
kind of act like that I i I'm still I
don't know I'm totally on edge I don't
think the evidence is that strong and
direct
everything I've even read when the US
says the FBI says they depicted some IP
addresses that are known to be used by
the rings well they could have come on
after somebody else did the hack and
start making some threats of Union you
do this if you don't do this more going
to happen to it just as a phony phony
you know trying to trying to get the
movie stopped or something or 2 i'm
trying to be a little nut cake book
taking advantage of somebody else's have
and what if they have I mean so I think
there was anything is a funny thing is
this is a weird hack it's not going to
cost Sony any money probably make it a
money on the movie right and it's not
going to make the hacker any money see
so it's kind of in that pure sense
you're just trying to do the thing
you're not supposed to be able to do and
I grew up with a lot of that I was never
I never have to computer I never took
over a computer or anything but trying
to explore a system how can I get around
do things that shouldn't be possible
with baby in my case it was with these
chips or with these programming
languages but it was the same sort but I
understand the mentality really well
well I think what Theriot terrified is
going to get somebody's password then
you know it did our most personal
private emails and information just
could be exposed and like that could be
the new future of you know just have a
new earth and maybe companies will get a
little learning from this that they
should protect those emails a little
better in different ways they should
have them encrypted at least you know
this you know or they should not make
that amount of data that data huge
amounts of data graph was great and then
somebody suggested could have been by
the insider you shouldn't even be able
to do it if you're an insider we have no
I hope the computer systems with the
right security and every other company
should learn from the Sony example but
they won't there's a one company saying
oh we better go and change everything
about our storage and set up a whole new
data centers and make sure that if any
quantity of data is being grabbed it we
have to have a personal contact to make
sure it's the person and their approval
you know none of that's going on none of
those changes are being done we talked
about it only Walt an emergency grabbing
us emotionally and then we forget about
it and I know that's been always been
the case and it always will I love that
you've been a great defender of Kim calm
who I interviewed for this podcast and
he speaks very highly of you and and the
concept that
I've become a defender of his also then
it's it's your words that you know he
was basically the post office and you
wouldn't arrest the post office for
somebody says there are legal things
right yeah yeah you don't yet you don't
shut down the post office if somebody
selling drugs for it you go for the drug
center did you think it's possible for
someone to do something as grand as Kim
calm did with the file sharing service
or do you think things of the internet
has been to colonized now I governments
and corporations you know sometimes you
do something that's not better than what
other people are doing but yours catches
on like a fad spreads word of mouth your
timing is right what you offer is right
the price is right and he had a huge
service I never used it i never knew
about it when it existed but they say
that he encouraged the sharing of movies
by the fact that if you had if you
posted something that was popular to a
lot of people to get then you got paid
for it and the only thing that people
really making money off of was if they
posted movies illegally and of course he
gave the studio's the right to even go
in and take any link down themselves
funny thing is the movie still stayed
there so i think the next guy that tried
to post it's a movie it was already
there made it easier to repost it under
a different address i don't know all the
details of that but i'll tell you he
still was um you could do the same
things with dropbox yeah you could do
the same things with dropbox if it
caught on for that and you know then
you'd have to start shutting things down
dropbox never gave a studio the right to
take off illegal movies being chaired on
dropbox which they have been you know no
studio no he gave them more rights than
anybody to shut things down he probably
should have taken a stronger stance you
know against them but what he did it's
very hard they couldn't even find a
felony charge the only way they're
trying to make it a felony is saying
that he armed oh except false
information through the through the mail
because he told them i took down all
these sites that you said to i took them
all down but it did was eat you know how
you if you believe a file on your
computer the file is still there
somewhere right it's just that there's
no way to get to it he took down the
links the aggressive links to those
files but the actual data stays on a
hard disk and there that's a phony
charge and then they've charged it with
racketeering because
his business was so big it was in
multiple countries you know well you can
accuse for Apple being racketeering
because they do some of their businesses
in in Ireland are you still making
counterfeit two-dollar bills yes are you
really yes last I am any condition
making them I have a good stack that's
current and fresh I don't have one other
time tonight unfortunately and I love it
no it's very good what's the purpose of
you do that just for you cuz you go
first of all yet because i can because
it's unusual i like unusual things two
dollars bills are unusual bills on
sheets or unusual bills in a pack a
pattern of paper is unusual perforated
shouldn't tear them off smelling looking
new the serial number start end with the
exact same digits on every bill um it's
so unusual I like it and also the fact
that i discovered that it's legal tender
the printer that makes them for me the
paths for me in los gatos gets the
supplies from a higher quality printer
they meet the specs of the US government
and if they meet the specs of the US
government by law they are legal tender
and I have had the Secret Service
challenge me three times to two times a
challenging two times and each time they
okayed the bills is being legitimate
once they read me my Miranda rights and
I give him a fake ID and everything I
don't have you ever done story if you're
making fake IDs no no no yes I nobody
else could do it back in though that day
because the printers for personal
computers weren't good enough to print a
photo I did photo IDs I had a super
expensive printer and a dye sublimation
printer and I print photo IDs were
backstage passes so I gave him another
thing that said I was um a laser safety
officer and I have an eye patch in the
picture and Secret Service got
bamboozled and they've been in the bills
were built they said they had passed the
bills are good wow so tender their legal
tender I've been spinning them for 20
years I sell sheets of 42 dollar bills
by hand right here at cellule sheet for
five gold i buy it if you have you know
is it you don't have to worry Joe thing
where picasa would always sign in checks
but no whatever cash to check because
they wanted the Picasso autograph your
hand
these other bills but no I had young
people you can spend really i think some
people just go up to her props been made
bought for two dollar bills for five
bucks and you know 11 sometimes people
have told me they know a dark bar where
they can get away with it he's been on
them but they most you know nobody has
to take them you can get arrested for
them but you cannot get convicted
because you are in the right they are
legal tender secret services charge that
they've approval ahead what about done
we have to hurry up though yeah no
problem okay i have a happiness list on
my website things that make me happy an
8th grade teacher in Atlantis wrote me a
very nice email and said that she
assigns the assignment to her class for
them to come up with a happiness list so
uh let me ask you a couple things
related to happiness what was your
favorite toy is a child i'm gonna guess
i can't remember early childhood cuz we
forget those things yeah I definitely
remember my rector sense that was a big
big part of my life but you see I was
extremely young at the age people had
toys I did a whole ham radio that I
built myself transmitter and a receiver
these were these were ok so it's hard to
say what's your favorite toy other kids
and making mud pies you listening to
radio fire on a walkie-talkie but about
walkie-talkie I never had one I had a I
have a house to house in a comp but I
built it myself it wasn't like a toy you
buy then the next question is what's
your favorite toy is an adult or have
you not invented that yet um I would say
it's definitely the smartphone the
iphone that I have because you get app
after after after appt dislike fun fun
little toy games and they cost nothing
we adults spend nothing to get our toys
and and look I take my kid to the
carnival and the throes of darts to get
bigger stuffed animals yeah I spend a
hundred bucks you know on the kid gettin
cool it with his toys his fun but we get
r done for free I was renting a car to
come down here today at the airport and
the woman was very nice at the budget
counter Laura and she was Anna what are
you going today going for a drive and I
said I'm gonna meet
yeah I kept the conversation I said you
have any questions for it she's a dumb
to slow down with the phones she goes I
bought my kids the five i bought my kids
the sixes I have the five and I was
gonna get a six but now there's a 6 plus
she's like she was complaining that the
phones are coming out too I thought you
were gonna say she was gonna tell you
sure take an uber probably um what is
the greatest advice you've ever been
good leaving your own goals keep your
ideals actually young ideals through
life don't grow up even the teacher said
that my dad said it in many ways okay in
closing is there any words of wisdom or
advice for the people of the earth you'd
like to share well I try to try to
decide who you are by age 20 because
your personality is going to kind of
freeze and if you're over 21 except
everyone a lot of people different you
know and you're good but because they
are different think they're leaving you
let us make the bed they're just good in
their different universe so accept it
basically except everyone be nice you're
judged by how much people like you why
do you have conflicts and have people
not like this that's my vice and I look
like you're beautiful human being and
I'm happy to know your stuff thank you
so much for making time for me to it
yeah we're gonna see you tonight all
right oh great actually my mother said
the greatest advice he ever got was
control-alt-delete hi man I had the
thing down I'm quiet now we're going to
ask them
I end every podcast without question but
that's the most meaningful at Christ
maybe not the best I love it thanks
ladies and gentlemen of the class of 97
wear sunscreen if I could offer you only
one tip for the future sunscreen would
be it a long-term benefits of sunscreen
have been proved by scientists where is
the rest of my advice has no basis more
reliable than my own meandering
experience I will dispense this advice
enjoy the power and beauty offer you
another mine you will not understand the
power and beauty of your youth until
they fade it but trust me 20 years you
look back at photos of yourself call in
a way you can't grasp now how much
possibility later for you and how
fabulous you really looked you are not
as fat as you imagine don't worry about
the future or worry but know that
worrying is as effective as trying to
solve algebra equation by chewing
bubblegum a real troubles in your life
they're apt to be things that never
crossed your worried mind kinda lied
sighs you at 4pm on some idle Tuesday do
one thing everyday that's scares you
so don't be reckless with other people's
hearts and put up with people who are
reckless with yours Plus don't waste
your time on jealousy sometimes you're
ahead sometimes you're done the race is
long in the end Tony with yourself
remember compliments you receive forget
the insults you succeed in doing this
tell me how keep your old love letters
throw away your old bank stages stretch
don't feel guilty if you don't know what
you want to do with your life most
interesting people i know didn't know
what 22 that they wanted to do with
their lives some of the most interesting
40 year olds i know still don't get
plenty of calcium because who needs
you'll miss them maybe you'll marry
maybe you won't maybe you'll have
children maybe you won't maybe you'll
divorce at 40 maybe you'll dance the
funky chicken on your 75th wedding
anniversary whatever you do don't
congratulate yourself too much or berate
yourself either your choices are half
chance so are everybody else's enjoy
your body use it every way you can and
be afraid of it or what other people
think of it the greatest instrument
you'll ever own
dance even if you have nowhere to do it
but in your only read the directions if
you don't follow them do not read beauty
magazines they will only make you feel
ugly brother together we'll make it
thank you
get to know your parents you never know
when they'll be gone good nice to your
siblings hair your best into your past
most likely mistake me for the future
understand the friends come and go but
with a precious few you should hold on
work hard bridge the gaps geography and
lifestyle
the older you get the more you need the
people who knew when you yo live in New
York City once but leave before it makes
you hard live in Northern California
once but leave before it makes you soft
travel except certain in alien truths
prices will rise politicians willful
angered you two will get old and when
you do you fantasize that when you will
yo prices were reasonable politicians
were noble and children respected their
elders respect your elders don't expect
anyone else to support you maybe you
have a trust one maybe you'll have a
wealthy spouse but you never know when
either one might run up a mess too much
with your hair or by the time you're 40
it will look 85 be careful whose advice
you buy but be patient with those is
applied twice the form of nostalgia
dispensing it it's a way of Ashima cast
from the disposal wiping it off
over the ugly parts and recycling it a
more than it's worth but trust me on the
sunscreen
hey
Oh